CDC
uh boss head boss testified at a
congressional inquiry yes and they said
this is what we call the Tim Dylan show
final episode on YouTube so we hope you
all enjoy this is the final episode here
on YouTube before because in America
you're not allowed to show a C-SPAN Club
yeah it's wild too you showed me these
clips earlier before we went on air yeah
uh you've got uh
you've got that former head of the CDC
uh director Redfield saying it was gain
of function and they were flying and
they covered it up and he's not part of
it he's literally turning States
evidence and I don't think you should
show this Tim
no well no no no no no no but what about
the people that want to buy athletic
greens we need the views
we need the views [__] Bluetooth
dick pills we need the views hey Awesome
by the way I love the media saying Jones
sells dick pills what's the word I will
assure you our dick pills work they work
and what's the worst thing that could
happen Michael Hastings or you know hey
whatever you gotta do it we gotta do it
there's nothing more 20 23 than Dying
For The View count so please show this
CDC clip okay we got a couple of these
which one do you want we've got uh the
damning one the one that gets us
viewer this is the head of the CDC yes
testifying and then we've got a Matt
Tybee being attacked for Joe Rogan
let's do head of CDC first y'all do that
here's there's that of the CDC
one other path of questioning for you Dr
Ripple proponents of This research
claimant may result in vaccines or maybe
even stop a pandemic
Dr Redfield has gained a function
created any life-saving vaccines or
Therapeutics to your knowledge not to my
knowledge has gain of function stopped a
pandemic in your opinion
you know in the contrary I think it
probably caused the greatest pandemic
our world has seen
do you find any tangible benefits uh to
gain a function research at this time
I personally don't but I do want to
stress I think the men and women that
supported
are people of good faith because they
truly believe it's going to lead to a
potential benefit I disagree with that
assessment gain of function research is
let's make scary viruses even scarier
let's get the government to give us more
money and increase the endowments and
the budget and he just said gain a
function caused the cover to be a living
right he just said that and he goes on
and this by the way this is not a crank
this is not somebody we found on 6th
Street in Austin which is lovely this
time of year this is the ex head of the
Center for Disease Control yeah but I
think fact Checkers say we shouldn't air
this well and by the way we got more
clubs because I know you show them to me
yes we have more a bunch of other clubs
where he went through how he knew it was
going to function he knew it was a
weapon but they wouldn't let him say
anything excluded him from the meetings
so let's put those on too because like
if we're gonna go out let's go out in
style okay well let me look up which
calyps those were from here to function
stuff is now coming out I remember in
the old day is when you'd be kicked off
social media for saying that stuff but
now it's starting to come out and people
are basically I think becoming more
aware of the fact that this is not uh oh
um a naturally occurring virus it was
manipulated genetically in a lab it was
manipulated for a reason and then it
might have leaked someone might have
leaked it I don't know that anyone's
gotten that far yet but I think it's
becoming a widely established belief
that this idea that it was a bat
that you know somebody ate a bat in the
soup no no no no
it was about fauci's god let's play the
evil C-SPAN clip of a man that needs to
be arrested the former advocacy who does
he think he is he's a shut up let's play
Club two Dr Robert Redfield testifies on
three unusual events in the Wuhan lab in
September 2019 before they released it
listen to this
bad person here it is that I will say if
you go back and look it's Declassified
now and I'm sure you all have your
classified briefings but the
Declassified information now in
September of 2019 three things happened
in that lab
one is they deleted the sequences
it was highly irregular researchers
don't usually like to do that second
thing they did was they changed the
command and control of the lab from the
civilian control to the military control
highly unusual and I've been involved in
doing your slabs when I was in the
military and the third things they did
which I think is really telling is they
led a contractor redo the ventilation
system in that Laboratory
so I think clearly there was strong
evidence that there was a significant
event that happened in that laboratory
in September it's now been Declassified
you can read it I'm sure there's more
classified information around so a
significant event no this is just
information I agree with you tonight
yeah
this is evil yeah okay but there's a
worse clip I mean just listen to this
horrible person uh here is uh he's just
doing it for clout
yeah X Out of the CDC is just trying he
he just wants Cloud yeah he's not
turning against the whole system I have
the quotes here that's right where he
says
listen to these quotes listen to this
horrible person Redfield explains his
rational knowing there's several
suspicious events occurred at the Luan
Institute of Urology in the months
proceeding so we just played that club
but let's play a clip here
let's play the clip here of uh clip six
MTG talks to the former CDC director
Robert Redfield reveals covid-19 virus
was likely created by gain of function
research which he admits was going on
which faucy says it wasn't even though
in the files he calls it gain of
function which is illegal by the way
it's a death penalty yeah here it is
Dr Redfield did you agree in your
opinion with Dr Anderson's assessment at
the time that this virus did look
engineered
I was concerned because of the presence
of the fury and cleavage site that we've
talked about and I think it's important
to understand what that cleavage site
does
that cleavage site totally changes the
orientation of The Binding domain of
covid so it now which could not see the
H2 receptor which is the human receptor
it totally changes the orientation now
so it has high affinity for a human
receptor so that fear in cleavocyte
bothered me it didn't seem that it
belonged there and then when you look at
the sequences that it used it's beyond
the committee but I know many of you
have looked into it the sequences that
they used in those 12 nucleotides for
arginine where the Arginine sequences
nucleotide triplet that encoded for the
human arginine so why did this virus
have the Arginine sequences for human
they're not bad it was very
disconcerting to me it looked like this
virus was engineered was this odd it's a
billion years ago is this something that
would be in line with gain of function
research
usually she goes to the wild but this
she actually seems like on target you
know she can get a little nuts but this
seems like she got the glasses she's
like okay she's in the zone
um yeah it's a problem we cooked it up
Us in China was it was it a joint effort
was it a please let me know it's a
little bit of us it wasn't just China
right as much as I hate the Communist
Chinese who are the most evil thing on
earth right uh it's a total setup about
he talks about that in another club yeah
there's articles in Nature and Science
in 2015 when good scientists win why is
the federal government weaponizing
coronavirus with a gain of function
using HIV Spike protein which is the
cleavage point it's like that's the horn
or the
the Rhino horn it's what plugs into the
cells
and so
he goes through all of that in the clip
that this obviously had to be done here
because it was done here in 2015 it was
a huge Scandal so then Western money
Bill Gates Peter does it they talk about
the hearing this is not my opinion for
YouTube I mean you play the clips they
move it to Wuhan
so there's plausible deniability so
obviously the Chinese have able traded
our government they're involved but they
allowed it to be taken there to do
illegal stuff in a third-party country
right just when they're doing in Ukraine
and in in the UK and other places now
all of this may be true but the
vaccine's still good right
absolutely uh I mean let's just come out
and say at least that's good it's safe
and effect it is and you should get as
much of it as you can
uh well actually people should research
that they said it was 99 effective the
96 effective 95 effective than 67
effective and 45 effective and now the
new studies uh are that within six
months you have a lower immunity and a
higher rate of infection sickness and
death yeah but I mean listen I still
think you should take it I'm a big
Pfizer nice to go and get it you know
what I mean let's be honest there's too
many people there's a lot of people I
think you should give it to your
children yeah
double boost them right and you know
those little guys they're eating too
much yeah I mean seriously well who's
gonna lie we're all sick of these loud
ass kids yeah look it's a legal way to
get rid of them now do you think because
listen it seems like it's somewhat of an
ineffective way it's a legal way to get
rid of their sickness which is being
alive right right I feel like it's in it
it's a I feel like it's an ineffective
way to depopulate the Earth well what I
do think is that this was an opportunity
for a company to make a trillion dollars
maybe every year at infinim
um no but I agree but then why did they
bring something out
that was so wonderful I mean right I
mean you did so much good I mean the
point is you take this shot you get 10
years on your life right by the way
that's the joke folks the point is we're
still at a point where you're not
supposed to talk about this remember
we're Vindicated that it came out of the
lab we're Vindicated that it's not
working we're vindicate all all this
stuff so you know imagine the sensors
watching us feeling all powerful you're
being attacked by it too dumbasses
athletic greens no but I agree uh well
they do they do say that vitamins are
key it's good
you gotta take the [__]
I take athletic green do you have a
vitamin in your hand right now you gave
me an athletic green enema this morning
yes we have to it's more effective now
all of this stuff coming out you put in
a turkey baster yes of course well yeah
you have to we had to we had to put you
in stir ups and treat you like a
pregnant woman which you are because
everyone's everything actually I
identify as a woman yes and this are you
doing anything South by Southwest I have
no I'm just here I mean that would be a
great place to get married you know and
let's see if Google would let us use
their like tent I think we should do a
mock marriage yeah at the Google tent
but it should be a polyamory yeah you
and I should Roseanne
I don't know we should all marry a
Pfizer shot I don't know what the fourth
thing is find a fifth grade
remember that Stephen Colbert yeah
really cringe thing with the Dancing
Yeah dancing syringes we should marry a
dancing Saran
I'm serious